[Music]
what's up guys you're listening to real
estate the ramsy way this episode is all
about making smart decisions with your
mortgage and while it's the only kind of
debt that I'm okay with I'm not okay
with just any mortgage option in fact
most types of mortgages out there suck
and lenders will use these crappy
mortgages to get you into a house for as
little upfront as possible so you feel
like you're getting a good deal then
they can charge you tons of interest and
fees not to mention keep you in debt for
way longer but there's a better way to
go about home financing and it's
actually incredibly simple so stick
around to find out how so I did this
video on my YouTube channel about a week
ago and for some reason it just blew up
and people are very interested in this
idea with mortgage interest rates being
super high right now and uh we had
showed a stat there in the very
beginning at you know January of 2022 it
was like 3% by May of 20222 it was 10%
so we've been seeing the spike and
adjustable rate mortgages and I want to
get your take
10% uh mortgage rates are 10% well no
the actual the amount of people doing
them 3% amount doing adjustable rate
mortgages has gone way up I got you okay
yeah not the interest rate itself okay
so I wanted to cover this and I just
watched your real estate lesson in
Financial Peace University where you
cover a lot of these mortgage traps but
a lot of people are going this might be
my ticket to home ownership Dave and
this article unpacks what's going on
here your ticket to foreclosure yeah
arms have started to recover more from
more than a decade of disinterest from
both consumers and lenders they're
returning to the fold amid a sharp
increase in home prices and fixed
mortgage rates that began in early 2022
as the housing market begins to thaw
from a year of depressed demand more
potential sellers begin to list their
homes could arms help more prospective
buyers get a foot in the door of their
first home you understand this this
passive aggressive
question statement here is on
experion which is this would be the
credit bureau yeah who what what is
their vested interest in
this getting you in debt and keeping you
in debt because you're all worried about
their FICO score hello they'll make
money if you get a mortgage and they
have to run the score this is a
money-making scheme for them this is
yeah we love debt and so we're experien
we're going to passively aggressively
ask is this a way for people to get
their foot the door that sounded very
soft sounded like a suggestion to me
sounded like a conspiracy to me Ser oh
they have a new stat in here today the
share increased from 3% it was for much
of the decade to as high as 133% by
October mortgages of the mortgage
original are going out there 3% used to
be adjust so 97% were not doing
adjustables and now 87% are it's down as
of April 2023 they say it's now 8% of
all new mortgages thank God it's taking
a dip so do we need to talk about this
well I want you to just share why
they're a bad idea cuz people don't
understand and there's a funny clip from
the office with Michael Scott falling
for one of these and he's like well no
it's a 30 and she's like no it's 10 over
and so I wanted you just to run the
analysis on who is this for why are
people doing this why should they stay
away okay um we'll get real technical to
help you but before we do that let's
just say this all right if you buy a
mortgage that
adjusts in an increasing interest rate
in
environment what are you expecting it to
adjust
to up well that's dumber than a rock on
the
surface interest rates are moving up and
you're buying a mortgage that allows
them to in and gives you the probability
of a higher interest rate later let's
just start with that
stupid okay the second thing is this
let's say interest rates stay the same
or go down slight
lightly here's what you're going to
discover your mortgage interest on your
adjustable rate mortgage is going to go
up even if rates go down a little or
stay the same here's why your mortgage
is adjusted based on an
index and a spread over the index let's
just do a simplified version okay let's
say you took out a 4% adjustable rate
mortgage and it's supposed to be 2% over
the index that would mean the index
would be two 2 + 2 is 4 okay and and if
the but the index however when you start
your brand new mortgage they move you in
on a bait and switch because the index
is already higher would would would
would give you the spread would already
give you a higher interest rate
today than you're getting today so
instead of the more okay let's say we're
getting a 4% adjustable rate the IND
index is two your spread is two so that
2 plus 2 equal 4 okay but it's not two
the index today in that case would be
more like
2.6 so the interest rates would have to
go
down 6 for your rate to remain the same
the next time it adjusts y'all follow
how I'm doing this okay because the
index plus your spread equals your
interest rate and the index is already
cheated up when you go in so rates would
have to go down in order for you to do
this a and so it's a big gamble so it's
not a big gamble you're 100% dead on
going to have an increase there's no
gamble about it you're you you know and
you bought the house on short-term
thinking thank God it's Friday oh God
it's money I can pay this payment like
this payment's even going to be around
on the first adjust you're going to see
an increase it's not a gamble Almost
100% of the time because again rates
would have to go down to get your spread
to keep your spread on the index far
enough down okay it just doesn't work so
this all came from mortgage companies
protecting themselves in
1982 I was selling real estate the first
adjustable rates came out then okay
because interest rates had gone to
17% remember that and more and money
market rates back then we had these
things called savings and loans Money
Market rates on your savings were
12% wow you could get 12% on your
savings account well let me help you
with this the local savings and loan
makes a loan in the 70s on a mortgage
4% they are receiving 4% on
$100,000 interest rates shoot up that's
a 4% fixed rate
loan now in order to get $100,000 into
the savings loan or into the bank they
got to pay out 12 but they're only
receiving four that's a problem that's
called in banking they call that
disintermediation your your butt's
upside down mathematically and so that's
one of the things called The Savings and
Loan industry to crash that's why I
brought up Savings and Loans it's one of
the things that crashed them was
disintermediation it wasn't fraud it was
that because they had millions of
dollars of mortgages on the books at a
fixed rate and all of a sudden they're
having to pay more than they're
receiving to get new savings deposits so
they said to themselves self I don't
like this next time these rates go up
we're going to have a portion of our
portfolio that adjusts up as interest
rates go up and so the adjustable rate
mortgage was born so to protect the
banks against an increasing interest
rate environment so they don't get stuck
with a bunch of low interest mortgages
on the
books TAA the first the first adjustable
rate mortgage I sold was the fixed rates
were 14% 1982
1983 the fix rates were 14% our
adjustables were 12
wow and I said man nobody will ever buy
these things and that was 1982 and
they're still buying them still around
today so just transferring the risk from
the lender onto you it's 100% what it
does it transfers the the risk of higher
interest rates from the lender it
ensures that the lender is always going
to freaking make money for MS to this is
a bank play it ain't got anything to do
with being a blessing to you and
allowing according to experience help
prospective buyers get their foot in the
door bull crap hadn't got anything to do
with prospective buyers it's got to do
with banks and one thing you can count
on on banks is Banks protecting Banks
it's what they do and they've been good
at it for a long time that's why their
Furniture is nicer than yours that's why
their building is bigger than yours it's
not an accident Santa Claus didn't build
those freaking Towers in the
skyline it was you you built them with
this kind of crap where you give these
Banks your money John one of the things
that has happened uh with this surge in
real estate is a surge in real estate
values uh a lot of you are sitting on a
home that is worth a whole lot more than
it was uh 20 minutes ago than it was two
years ago than it was three years ago
there was a big hurricane and I can't
remember the name of it that hit Florida
and did massive destruction before
Katrina hit New Orleans so several years
back in other
words and after that hurricane
State Farm made the decision that they
were no longer doing policies that
covered the value of the
house instead they're going to do
policies homeowners policies that they
State the value MH and State Farm was
the biggest player in the homeowners
insurance world and so everyone followed
suit and and uh Sometimes some of the
policies uh you know words you buy a
house for 300,000 bucks we'll make up a
number and
you buy a homeowner's policy for 300,000
bucks to cover the home you just bought
and it might have an inflation clause on
it that the next year it's a little bit
more next year it's a little bit more
but it would be it would not be unusual
for a whole bunch of you listening right
now to have a home that you paid 300 for
that you've got $350,000 worth of
coverage with those inflation kickers on
them and the thing's worth 550,000 and
it burns down and you can't rebuild it
you can't build a driveway with $300,000
right now yeah and so what what I'm
telling you is is that you H it is now
incumbent upon you because the insurance
business changed as of that hurricane
that I can't remember the name of uh the
insurance business changed and it's
basically stated value plus or minus
inflation kickers and the inflation
kickers Aren't Enough wow and so you
have to revisit your homeowners
insurance once a year and make sure you
have the right amount of coverage for
the value of the house how are you
evaluate your your home on an annual
basis like that I mean you can jump on
just one of the websites and look at it
you're not going to be far off but you
kind of know I got $189,000 worth of
coverage and this house is worth 600
Grand our neighbors just sold their
house for yeah so you know you're like
way off and so you can toss that to your
insurance provider and they they'll
they'll do a little research on it and
tell you what to cover the house for but
you need to update your coverage because
the value of your home is growing and
your policy's not you know what really
freaks me out is the millions of people
who in 2020 and
2021 when the housing prices started to
Surge took out a big home equity loan to
pay for their new bathroom they want to
get done during that Gap and now not
only is the insurance coverage not there
but they're going to be on the hook for
that that loan they're going to be
staring at a burnd down lot holding a
check that can't replace the driveway
plus you owe me you owe us this equity
loan exactly you what a mess if You'
refinanced the first mortgage they would
have required you to update the
insurance but many times a home equity
loan doesn't wow you're exactly a mess
you're exactly right so you could you
could literally be upside down on the
house like like on an old days old days
in a car yeah that kind of thing so what
I'm telling you is get online at Ramsey
solutions.com and click the ELP for
insurance and get a free quotee on your
car insurance and your homeowners
insurance and keep your homeowners
insurance updated uh for the right
amount of coverage because if your house
burns down and you have 50% of it
covered you're going to build a very
small house in that lot I mean you're
going to be screwed up and if you got a
mortgage you know your mortgage is
probably less than that you're going to
end up with nothing zero you going to
pay off the mortgage and have a burned
up lot yeah that's all you're going to
have and so that's you're going to be in
a mess so make sure you keep your
coverage up to date and always price
shop it with one of these uh Insurance
Brokers now the difference in a broker
and somebody like State Farm uh one of
these name brands U you know if they've
got a u a a celebrity endorser they're
probably a captive company meaning State
Farm can agents can only sell State Farm
or a lizard that's right you that lizard
thing that's the other one yeah um and
so you can you know Nationwide can only
sell Nationwide and so you know that
they they're captive agents is what we
call them in the insurance business so
instead you want to get a broker that
shop a bunch of different companies and
find you the best price in your
situation and so many times when someone
goes to Ramy solutions.com clicks on the
ELP and gets with an insurance broker in
shops they not only get the right amount
of coverage because their house has gone
up in value but they also get a cheaper
rate and uh so if you're buying the same
amount of insurance a lot of people save
7 800 bucks a year by changing their car
and their homeowners or Auto and
homeowners over and um because just
people are we're fairly lazy about our
insurance shopping sure are uh we get it
in place it's it's a rip it and forget
it right I mean you just put it on there
and you pay the bill you pay the pill
you pay the bill unless something comes
up and shakes you up but I'm telling you
right now I don't know what the
percentages but I would guess um north
of 50% of you listening to me right now
that own a home do not have the proper
amount of coverage on your home because
your home's gone up in value and you
didn't update your coverage and the
insurance companies do not updated they
are not they took that responsibility
away from themselves and gave it to you
and having sat in this middle of a
street with somebody watching their
House burn down on a couple of different
occasions that sounds like a nightmare
on top of a nightmare oh it is it's one
of the most horrible things to go
through
emotionally whether you're buying a new
home or refinancing your current home
you should never sign on the dotted line
until you're sure it's the best decision
for you that's why I recommend reaching
out to my friends at Church Hill
mortgage their experienced ramsy trusted
loan specialist can save you time
headache and help you finance a home the
smart way just click the link in the
show notes or go to ramsy solutions.com
morgage to get connected Jeff is going
to start us off this hour in Cincinnati
hi Jeff how are
you hey Jeff I'm I'm doing good Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's
up well uh I'm kind of a new follower I
just found you earlier this year had
some questions about potentially
refinancing our house um we originally
bought it back in January of
2021 um this was obviously before we
knew you and we we got a 30-year loan um
at 2 and a
half% um and now kind of considering do
we do we move to a 15-year but my
biggest concern with that is that we're
giving up that 2 and a half% rate to go
somewhere around 5% or so you're right
to be concerned I would not I would not
do that you're
right okay no you keep the existing keep
the existing mortgage you have if you
calculate a 30-year mortgage and you
calculate a 15-year mortgage at the same
interest rate in your case two and a
half and you pay the difference like you
like you took out a 30 and you pay the
extra amount as and the difference
between a 15 payment Authority payment
it will pay off in exactly 15
years okay you do not have to refinance
to pay a loan off in 15 years you just
have to pay it like it's a 15-year
payment and it'll pay right out um or
more of course and then it would pay out
even sooner so never refinance just to
move from a 30 to a 15 uh uh because
you'd take on the closing costs at a
minimum and in this case you'd go up an
interest rate so you never do that just
pay extra on it and you'll get
there okay um that was easy wasn't it as
far
as as far as how much uh like house I
can afford uh we were well within the um
25% um kind of calculating it off of Two
and a half% rate that we have great um
but with with rates now I know we're not
refinancing um but that would obviously
put us probably closer to the 30% mark
do we have well it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you're you're fine you
know the reality is your house payment
is a fourth of your take home pay at a
15E on two and a half and so you're fine
the reason we put that in place is not
to keep people from buying homes and
John people are really mad right now
about you hate home house prices
apparently I hate home home ownership
and I'm an unrealistic old um Boomer or
whatever other terms of derision you can
throw up my bald head but the um the I
don't care if you get a house you can't
afford it doesn't affect me it affects
you if you buy a house you can't afford
Jeff's in good shape he's not got any
issues but here's the thing and I've
been answering this question the same
way for 30 years like we have people
call us from California well Dave you're
you know you can't buy a house in
California for that uh that means you
can't buy a house buy House California
for that that's what that means you also
may not be able to buy a Bentley uh you
also may not be when I grew up that this
County that we live in is the 11th
wealthiest County in the in the
wealthiest County in Tennessee
Williamson County Tennessee where you
and I are sitting right now where both
of us live now when I was growing up
that's where the rich people lived and
we said stuff like you can't afford to
live there and you know what not
everybody can afford to live there
everybody can afford to live on Rodeo
Drive or in downtown Manhattan or
downtown Tokyo or downtown London it's
freaking expensive and so sometimes you
just have to say I can't afford it
number one but number two here the
reason for this is we know from the data
of doing this for 30 years that your
most likely way to become wealthy is to
get your home paid off as soon as
possible and all other Debs too because
it it frees up your most powerful wealth
building tool and so if you keep a
mortgage around like it's a pet for your
whole life because you're thinking well
I'm always going to have a mortgage and
the only way I can afford a mortgage the
only way I ever going to get a house
because I'll never get a house I'll
never get a house I'm so stuck and it's
just not fair and life's not fair and
I'm a four-year-old in the cereal aisle
throw in a fit and I want Captain crunch
dad blame it you know and it's just like
and you're just everybody's acting like
that right now and so I'm sorry you I'm
I'm sorry that when I was a kid I
couldn't live in Williamson County I
couldn't afford it my family didn't make
that kind of money I'm sorry I had a
traumatized childhood I'm sorry but it's
it's the way life is and so you know the
answer is no the reason you tell
yourself no is so you can tell yourself
yes later so if you go buy a house you
can't afford and you go take car
payments out that you can't afford and
you go take which nobody can you go take
out a student loan and you go take out
MasterCard and visa and American
distress you're going to be normal and
normal is you work your whole life and
give all of the money you earn to
someone else in the form of payments and
retire broke and hope social insecurity
will take care of you who the crap wants
to be normal right and so you've got to
break this cycle and not be angry at me
or at the world or at Instagram or
Twitter or whatever it is you're angry
at this week um because house prices
went up I'm really sorry I I don't want
you to be upset I don't want you to not
have a house but also don't want you to
do something stupid that's going to keep
you broke your whole life I I'll throw a
third one on there Dave I have found in
my life when I've had a 30-year mortgage
and I've had a couple of those in the
15E I can have all the best intentions
with a 30-year mortgage but when it
comes down to it every single month some
somebody invites me out to a thing or
hey we're all going out to this thing
and whether I've got the best intentions
or I've got all the willpower in the
world it's really hard for me to make
that to double that payment or to make
that Gap payment between the 30-year
note is is requiring me to pay and what
I could be paying for that 15 year with
the 15 year I'm locked into it I got to
do it one of the things I figured out
when I very first started doing this
stuff with Financial Peace when I
started studying rich people is that put
smart things on
autopilot yes I don't want to think
about it 100% of the 15-year mortgages
pay off in 15 years or less yep 100% or
they get foreclosed on I mean 100% of
them do okay people that take out a 30
promising to pay a 15 the studies say
92% do not stick with the schedule I so
you if you if you put a system in place
that you have to be in the top 8% is the
only way you win you lose you're going
to that's dumb I just was listening to
some obesity researchers today and they
were talking about step one create an
environment where you can at least
attempt to be successful get the junk
out of your house yeah right you can't
have it all there and say I'm gonna make
good choices cuz you're not going to
make good choices James CLA talks about
that in atomic habits yeah talks about
the exact same thing what is it you're
trying to create a habit then don't put
stuff that's contrary to The Habit right
in front of you let's go to Suzanne out
in Spokane hey what's up Suzanne hi
there hi there how's it going I just
love that it rhymes Suzanne and Spokan
it just made me happy it's good to have
you Suzanne how can we help yeah good
thank you guys so much for taking my
call you got it what's up um so this is
basically what I've got so my husband
and I we moved up we're actually in the
North Idaho area so we're just kind of
over the border from Spokane okay we
moved here really unexpectedly last year
after my husband lost his job and it
just ended up being such a blessing he
got a job up here and we absolutely love
it
we don't want to leave we're closer to
family now and he got a good job here
he's been able to start a business so
he's actually working two jobs and I am
a stay-at-home mom now we've got two
baby girls congrats and so thank you so
it's really expensive here that's one
thing we didn't know we didn't know the
area that well but we love it so we're
determined to stay here okay and we were
actually able to pay off all of our debt
last month wow conrat
super exciting yes so in the midst of Co
and babies and this move and everything
we still managed to pay off our debt so
we own our vehicles all that and we're
inter rental but we've decided that we
want to go ahead and buy even though
this Market is really crazy and it's
really expensive here but we figured
since we're debt free we can go ahead
and pull the trigger and do it so we're
in the middle of purchasing a place that
we found so you already have a contract
out
yes we do we yeah we close here in a
couple weeks
okay yeah
so it is expensive and we know that you
know we we had started with a budget
that was a bit lower and we decided to
go higher because we just we found this
great property and it just seems like a
wonderful place to raise children and
since we're dedicated to staying in the
area we wanted to do it so you've laid
the groundwork to justify not making a
smart decision is that what
happened
is am I questioning the decision yeah
you've laid the
groundwork to have possibly made a not
great financial decision it sounds like
there's a lot of emotion behind this of
just excitement about getting in a house
and all all this so give us some details
about the the financial
aspect yeah so we when we first started
looking so we've been looking for months
and months with our
Realtor and we didn't have a super firm
budget in mind but we decided around the
450 Mark was we didn't want to go much
over that we felt we could really afford
that and still be able to save money but
in this market and in this area where we
live what you can get for
450 just doesn't even seem worth it
these aren't even really starter homes
they're not even really fixer uppers and
we just found that nothing in that price
range we were willing to go for so we
decided that we wanted to not only do a
house but get some property since we've
got little kids so we ended up finding
something but it's about a 100,000 more
so 550 than we initially started yeah so
now we're in the 550 range and how much
are you guys putting as the down payment
what
percent well we aren't because we're
both veterans so we're going through a
VA loan so we aren't actually putting
anything
down okay what's your take
home yeah so we are yeah we are going to
finance the whole thing um which puts us
at about a $2,500 a month mortgage on a
30-year yes okay yeah suzan all right
what's your question you're getting us
all fired up here I'm getting riled up
Suzanne how can we help well that's what
I I don't know if we can help you're
knee deep in this thing if I'm you I'm
getting out of this thing if there's
still time but you already signed a
contract so what what's your
question well my question is um should
we focus on saving money cuz know we're
in this we're going to be paying this
mortgage should we be saving money and
focusing on that or should we focus the
extra money that we have every month
towards this mortgage and get it down
you should have focused it before you
ever gotten this contract and had a
healthy down payment on a 15year uh
that's what I would feel better about I
don't love this idea of you guys getting
out of debt and then taking on over a
half million dollars on a mortgage and
thinking that they're doing you a favor
by giving you the VA loan is that not a
big part of your take home pay what is
your take-home pay it
is um right now well we've got several
different sources of income What's the
total here here's What's happen withan
you have created a
universe that you want to have you want
to be in this area you want your kids in
in this area well our kids need to go
ahead and have this too so you created
that as well and you've created a really
fungible flexible dollar amount we just
got a lot of money coming from this
place and that place and this place and
here's what you've done you've created a
cloud that allows you to a not see very
clearly and not have to see very clearly
which allows you to live in a fantasy
and now you've zeroed down in one of the
if not the hottest real estate markets
of all time so it takes a teeny tiny
correction and you are underwater in a
half million doll
house working side jobs that are kind we
kind of make this in you know it and
suddenly this zero down VA loan is a
nightmare because you're underwater and
you can't get out so tell me how much
money you make how much money comes into
the suzan and Company home every
month um
about um my husband's business is tough
we can't because it's it's a new
business but about a 100,000 a year
right now
is that take-home pay or is that gross
yeah that's
take-home so you're taking home about
$8,000 right right and your mortgage is
going to be uh over about 31% of your
take home pay is going towards the
mortgage and that's on a 30-year which
we never ever ever recommend we always
tell people to do the 15year fix rate
but you're here right but we're here
Suzanne how old are you
guys um 35 and 37 okay you've got a lot
of Life to Live and I want to see you
live it and I don't want to see you
drowning in this giant mortgage payment
with nothing down uh I've I've just
talked to too many people heard too many
stories uh and they start out like yours
star eyed about the housing market and
wanting to get in and we want the
property we got to have the yard and the
budget's flexible and we're not putting
anything down and all of a sudden they
can't breathe yeah and we get calls I'm
sure we'll take one during this show
where someone calls in and says we're in
over our
we put nothing down on this house and
we're drowning and so if there's time to
get out I mean it's just you sign well
you signed the contract so you sign the
contract I don't know what the situation
is there uh if you're stuck with this
thing you may want to look at increasing
income refinancing to a 15-year and
making sure that you can afford it but
as far as paying down the mortgage I
mean it's a little late for that
conversation because we're really we're
knee in this thing uh but we recommend
10 to 20% down to avoid PMI or more on a
15year where the T where the mortgage
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take on pay so so far every one of
the ru every one of the rules has been
broken which just hurts my heart because
I want to see you guys win and you've
worked so hard to get to this point
where your debt free and you're making
these decisions and I don't want to see
you step backwards and make a bad
financial decision for your
future listen the best most secure way
to buy a home is with the 100% Down plan
it might not be easy but trust me people
pay cash for homes all the time now if
you're going to go the mortgage route
let's recap what you need to know you
need to be completely debt free before
you do a mortgage you need 3 to 6 months
of expenses saved in an emergency fund
before you do a mortgage and you need a
down payment of at least 5% but ideally
20% and you should only choose
conventional fixed rate 15-year mortgage
with a monthly payment that's no more
than 25% of your take-home pay all right
guys thanks for tuning in and don't
forget to share this with a friend who
would enjoy it and make sure to tune in
for the next episode for expert tips on
how to sell a
home